the Second Industrial Revolution in the
United States assured in new
technologies and new ways of living and
working during the Gilded Age steel
electricity and the telephone allowed
railroads to crisscross the country
skyscrapers to rise out of cities
factories to hum along long after sunset
and business transactions to take place
instantly over hundreds of miles this
was the time when the United States
began its transition from a nation of
rural farmers to a nation of
city-dwelling factory workers so at a
glance the Gilded Age seems like a time
of radical change for the country but as
historians how can we tell just how much
change really occurred from 1865 to 1898
one way we can do this is to track over
time what changed and what stayed the
same from the beginning of the Gilded
Age to its end historians call this
process examining continuity and change
over time when we study history it's
important to look at continuities or
things that continued on the same as
they were before because it's really
easy to focus on how one aspect of
society really transformed during a
certain period of time and then forget
to account for the fact that almost
everything else didn't change at all but
it would be practically impossible to
track the changes in every aspect of
society so let's dial in on a few areas
since the major transformations came
through technology and business in this
time period and those are both aspects
of work I'm curious about how the kind
of work that people did and the way that
they did it changed over the course of
the Gilded Age and since I know that
cities grew a lot during this time
period let's also look at changes in
living patterns where people migrated to
and from and how they lived I'm also
curious about the extent to which these
changes in work and living patterns
affected the major ideas and culture of
the time did people's beliefs about
society change much during the Gilded
Age or was the culture of the United
States at the end of the 19th century
pretty much the same as it was at
the end of the Civil War so let's look
at the major trends in each of these
areas at the beginning and the end of
this time period so we can try to answer
the question how much change did
industrialization really bring during
the Gilded Age by the way I'm not gonna
go into a whole lot of detail on these
trends because we're doing a really big
overview of the Gilded Age here so if
you find that you're not familiar with
something that comes up just make a note
of it and you can look it up when you
have time okay first let's compare the
changes in work and business from 1865
to 1898 well in 1865 the United States
was still primarily a nation of farmers
although there were a good number of
people in the north and the West who
worked in mills and mines and on
railroads many african-americans had
transitioned from working as slave
laborers on plantations in the south to
working as sharecroppers where they
would work portions of plantations in
return for a pretty measly share of the
profits
in fact most work in the United States
was segregated by race
it was pretty uncommon for whites
African Americans Chinese laborers or
Mexican American laborers to work
side-by-side anywhere in terms of the
way businesses were organized the Civil
War had sowed some initial seeds of
business consolidation the industrial
might that had helped the north when the
Civil War made it easy for some large
companies to begin turning natural
resources into infrastructure how did
that compare to the state of work in
1898 well there were still plenty of
farmers and sharecroppers
although the mechanization of
Agriculture in the late 19th century had
a negative effect on many farmers
sending them to the city looking for
work by the end of the century more
people worked for someone else for wages
and worked for themselves for the first
time in American history a lot of this
factory growth was driven by new
business practices like mass production
on the assembly line which broke complex
tasks down into tiny steps so that no
one required much training to work in a
factory a process known as D skilling
women and children began working in
factories as well but as at the
beginning of the Gilded Age workplaces
still tended to be racially segregated
and by the end of the 19th century
businesses had undergone major
consolidation often using monopolistic
practices to dominate industries and fix
prices and wages in response many
workers began to organize labor unions
but they had pretty limited success so
overall I would say that
industrialization led to some pretty
major changes in the world of work
although work generally remained
segregated and the process of
transitioning from farms to factories
wasn't entirely complete during the
Gilded Age there was a huge shift
towards unskilled wage work and big
corporations next let's look at living
and migration patterns in 1865 only
about 20% of the population lived in
cities most of the migrants to cities
were Irish and German immigrants coming
from northern and western Europe most
African Americans continued to live in
the South in the immediate aftermath of
the Civil War and the cities themselves
had pockets of density and poverty like
New York City's Five Points neighborhood
but they weren't yet incredibly crowded
what about in 1898
well the percentage of the population
living in cities nearly doubled up to 40
percent several cities grew to more than
1 million people for the first time
during the Gilded Age and who was coming
to the cities changed as well political
and economic trouble at home led many
Southern and Eastern Europeans to head
for the factories in American cities and
african-americans also began to slowly
trickle northward in order to escape
sharecropping in Jim Crow this massive
influx of people meant that cities were
very dense and many people had to crowd
into tenements unsafe unventilated
ramshackle apartment buildings in 1900
the Lower East Side of Manhattan was the
most densely populated neighborhood in
the world so I would say that
industrialization also led to quite the
transformation in late
and migration patterns the factory jobs
available in American cities drew new
people to them from all over the country
and the world and also changed the
standards of living last let's map the
changes and continuities
in prominent cultural ideas over the
course of the Gilded Age although there
are lots of different ideas and forms of
cultural expression we could talk about
I'm gonna focus on ideas about the
economy and race and immigration since
those are so closely tied to the other
two categories of analysis we've got
here immediately after the Civil War
there was an intense push in Congress
and in the north to ensure racial
equality for African Americans with the
passage of the 13th 14th and 15th
amendments there was also a very strong
nativist or anti-immigrant sentiment
among white native-born protestants who
especially objected to the immigration
of Irish Catholics as far as the economy
went there were many people who argued
in favor of lays a Fair economics that
the government should engage in little
to no regulation of the market now was
pretty much the prevailing government
approach of the day right how does that
compare to 1898 well unlike in the
immediate post-war period racial
equality for African Americans had been
abandoned as a mainstream idea with the
rise of Jim Crow and rulings like the
1896 Supreme Court case Plessy versus
Ferguson which approved segregation
nativism was also still a force in
American life and it had even
intensified thanks to the flawed racial
pseudoscience known as social Darwinism
which suggested that people who were in
high positions in society both in terms
of race and wealth belong there because
they were the fittest but there were a
few reformers who were beginning to
question the effects of
industrialization like settlement house
founder Jane Addams or early muckraker
Jacob Riis so in terms of ideas and
culture it looks like there was actually
more content
then change over the course of the
Gilded Age there may even have been an
overall regression in ideas about race
and immigration in this time period
there were a few efforts to soften the
pains of industrialization and
urbanization but they weren't yet
widespread let's return to our question
then and see if we can formulate a
thesis statement to address the extent
to which industrialization brought
change from 1865 to 1898 from the
evidence we've gathered I'd say that the
technological and business advancements
of the Second Industrial Revolution
brought enormous changes to the ways
that people lived and worked in the
United States transforming the country
from a rural farming nation to an urban
industrial one but the major ideas about
immigration race and the economy didn't
change as much segregation and nativist
sentiments intensified over the time
period and efforts to rein in the
excesses of industrial capitalism we're
just getting started the major social
efforts to improve the lives and work of
this new urban population would have to
wait until the Progressive Era